bonjour à tous ravis de vous retrouver
sur public sénat pour suivre en direct
les questions cribles thématiques
aujourd'hui consacré à la situation de
l'emploi en séance et bien c'est le
ministre du travail et de l'emploi
françois rebsamen qui répondent aux
sénateurs tout de suite direction
l'hémicycle pour vos questions cribles
et beaucoup d'emplois sauvés dans le pas
de calais par exemple le site
d'arjowiggins à wizernes et menacé de
fermeture d'ici juin 2015
307 salariés en cdi plus les
intérimaires et les emplois indirects
sont concernés par cette décision
arc international perdra plus de 200
emplois malgré la reprise de
l'entreprise par un fonds
d'investissement américain
la compagnie my ferry link interdite
d'accès au port de douvres est également
menacé de la suppression de 600 emplois
mais j'aurais pu citer aussi mecaplast y
oxydes stora enso la française de
mécanique bridgestone tout dans le
pas-de-calais j'en passe
rien que donc sur ce département sur le
sujet très sensible du travail des
tâches est illégal ou détournés on ne
peut en rester là aussi au statu quo
monsieur le ministre
alors lorsque pierre laurent interpelle
le gouvernement sur le plan social chez
sanofi celui ci répond qu'il a été
négocié en fait il a été annulé par la
justice mais à coût de modification du
code du travail
vous avez rendu impuissant les salariés
face à cette saignée
monsieur le ministre quand comptez vous
inversez votre politique en donnant
notamment le pouvoir aux salariés de
s'opposer assez logique destructrice
souvent financière merci cher collègue
monsieur françois rebsamen ministre du
travail de l'emploi et de la formation
professionnelle et du dialogue sous
social va vous répondre je vous en prie
monsieur le ministre
merci madame madame la présidente
dre répondront aux sénateurs dominique
watrin vous saluant toutes et tous
bon il ya des thèmes que vous évoquez
c'est le sénateur qui vont auquel je
vais répondre tout à l'heure puisque
j'aurai d'autres questions notamment
liés aux emplois détaché au travail des
tâches est ce que vous évoquez
c'est un échec effectivement je ne les
paniers l'année 2014
c'est pas la peine d'en rajouter
monsieur le sénateur c'est en catégorie
à ses 188 mille emplois 1 ce qu'a
inscrit en plus catégorie a à pôle
emploi
donc c'est pas ça succède à des années
depuis 2010 qui s'accumulent les unes
aux autres
ainsi de 2008 à 2014 compris c'est un
million trois cent mille demandeurs
d'emploi en catégorie à
j'aurai l'occasion de préciser les
choses tout à l'heure mais inscrits à
pôle emploi et donc la chute de l'emploi
industriel puisque vous avez évoqué
l'emploi industriel notamment dans les
entreprises de votre département mais
pas uniquement la chute de l'emploi
industriel s'est elle a commencé à se
produire il ya fort longtemps plusieurs
2 dizaine d'années elle s'est accélérée
de 2002 à disons aujourd'hui pour pas
voilà de 2000 aujourd'hui puisque
l'emploi industriel est passé d'une part
qu'il représente est d'à peu près 17 17
et demi pour cent à 11 %
donc il ya eu une dégradation nette de
l'emploi industriel dans notre pays pour
y remédier parce qu'il ya une perte de
compétitivité des entreprises indéniable
le gouvernement a fait un choix et ce
choix c'est de redonner à travers le
pacte de responsabilité de solidarité
je m'excuse la réponse est courte mais
je peux pas faire autrement j'aurai
l'occasion d'y revenir
c'est de redonner des marges de
manoeuvre aux entreprises pour faire
quoi ben démarches pour investir pour
faire de l'apprentissage s'occuper des
jeunes et créer de l'emploi derrière
voilà très rapidement j'en suis désolé
ce que je pouvais vous répond merci
monsieur le ministre pour la réplique
monsieur matin oui je comprends bien que
les réponses sont contraintes par le
temps cela dit j'avais pause mis en
avant si la question des droits des
salariés dans les entreprises
je ne peux pas rester sans réponse sur
ce sujet quant à la section 6 du projet
de loi sur la croissance et l'activité
le gouvernement propose de réduire
encore les pouvoirs d'intervention des
salariés de contrôle de l'administration
en cas de licenciement collectif
cela dit je le dis ici très clairement
nous sommes prêts à travailler sur tous
les dossiers comme demain je le ferai
avec le ministre vidalis sur my fair
healing qu'il est temps de défendre en
effet le pavillon français de s'opposer
des décisions unilatérales qui bannit
bafoue nos intérêts nationaux
vous avez cité la question l'emploi
industriel il y a là aussi beaucoup de
projets innovants que l'état devrait
promouvoir et accompagner par exemple la
production d'éco emballages à base de
chanvre en lien que le site stora de
korben là aussi dans mon département
mais trop souvent très souvent il faut
s'opposer aux intérêts égoïstes des
multinationales et de leurs accus
actionnaires pour réaliser ses projets
en avez vous le courage et la volonté
politique
merci monsieur watrin la parole est à
monsieur claude bérit débat
pour le groupe socialiste merci madame
la présidente monsieur le ministre
dans le contexte de croissance
économique ralentie que nous connaissons
le chômage continue de progresser
il frappe le plus particulièrement les
plus de 50 ans mais aussi et surtout les
jeunes de qui ont de plus en plus de mal
à s'insérer sur le marché du travail
dans cette perspective vous avez
notamment impulser une politique
volontariste visant à permettre à ces
jeunes sans emploi d'acquérir une
première expérience professionnelle
pour cela vous avez largement développer
les contrats aidés et il faut signer que
les moyens budgétaires débloquer dans ce
but ont été à la hauteur de l'enjeu
près de 500 mille contrats aidés été
budgétés en 2014 et 445 1000e seront en
cet effort remarquable doit cependant et
ce sera le sens de ma question est remis
en perspective au regard de deux
éléments le premier de savoir qu'il est
le renne pâques
elle sur l'évolution du chômage le
second concerne les types de contrats
qui convient de privilégier
il apparaît en effet que les contrats
aidés créés dans le secteur marchand
comme les contrats initiative emploi
dont le coût est moins élevés permettent
une meilleure insertion dans l'emploi de
leurs bénéficiaires
on sait en revanche que les contrats
aidés dans le secteur non marchand comme
les contrats d'accompagnement dans
l'emploi ou les emplois d'avenir
s'adressent à des publics jeunes souvent
très éloignés de l'emploi auquel il
donne une première chance
professionnelle est l'occasion de
s'insérer sur le marché du travail
au delà de son coup on voit donc bien
que le recours aux contrats aidés doit
être adaptée en fonction des publics
ciblés et de ses effets attendus dans
ces conditions monsieur le ministre
au regard de la situation actuelle
comment comptez vous renforcer
l'efficacité de ces contrats merci
beaucoup mais ce ministre
vous entrez merci madame la présidente
madame messieurs les sénateurs et
sénatrices monsieur le sénateur claude
bérit débat
merci de votre question effectivement
les contrats aidés c'est une c'est une
politique qui est qui a été utilisée qui
est utilisé et qui permet de préparer
différents publics à l'insertion dans
l'emploi et il est normal que l'état
développe ses politiques pour vous dire
simplement vous avez rappelé des
chiffres qui était juste 445 1000
emplois aidés dans la loi de finances
initiale 2015
il ya eu des périodes où on a été
jusqu'à 800 mille emplois aidés huit
cent mille emplois aidés à la fin des
années 90 nous étions 1 800 mille
emplois aidés et encore au milieu des
années 2005 nous étions à 700 milles à
vous vous feriez bien de faire attention
vous étiez aussi est très utilisé la
différence avec avant de 2012 c'est que
beaucoup d'emplois aidés étaient
utilisés à des fins électorales ces
terres des très courts contrat le
contraire le contraire de ce que
demandait le contraire de ce que
demandaient les associations comme
alerte ou la fnar ski sur les
associations très sérieuse qui lutte
contre la pauvreté et je me rappelle que
le grenelle
de l'emploi qui est de l'insertion qui
s'est tenue à dijon même le président de
la république nouvellement élu nicolas
sarkozy était venu dire c'est vrai vous
avez raison il faut qu'on allonge la
durée des emplois aidés des contrats
aidés puisque six mois ne permet pas une
véritable insertion dans le travail
nous en sommes à 11 mois aujourd'hui et
vous a posé la question de la différence
entre les emplois dans le secteur
marchand et dans des contrats aidés dans
le secteur non marchand
la réponse que me fais depuis que je
suis ministre l'administration c'est de
dire que dans l'emploi l'emploi aidés
dans le secteur non marchand et bien un
meilleur effet un meilleur impact parce
qu'elle permet d'insérer des publics
moi je suis assez sensible à ce que vous
m'avez dit à travers votre question je
pense qu'il faut favoriser les emplois
aidés dans le secteur marchand également
et c'est pourquoi dans la loi de
finances initiale il y aura 80 mille
emplois qui seront destinés aux seniors
aux chômeurs de longue durée dans le
secteur marchand merci monsieur le
ministre monsieur bérit débat
merci de votre réponse monsieur ministre
effectivement je crois que les chiffres
qu'il a énoncées devrait vous permettre
à faire preuve d'un peu d'humilité
puisqu'ils ont été aussi bien utilisée
sous le règne à la présidence sarkozy
que sous tous les présidents bondon là
dessus moi je suis un fervent défenseur
des contrats aidés
je vous le dis et la question que je me
posais c'était effectivement quel est le
type de contrat le plus efficace dans le
secteur marchand ou dans le secteur non
marchand en sachant que dans l'insertion
marchand il peut y avoir alors est-ce
que c'est pas un effet d'optique hum hum
je dirais une meilleure insertion une
meilleure je dirais
réponse aux demandes du travail bon la
réponse du ministre me satisfait
pleinement dans la mesure où ils vont on
va travailler sur deux béquilles sur
deux pieds sur deux jambes secteur non
marchand et ses termes argent je vous
encourage monsieur le ministre à
poursuivre dans cette voie
merci cher collègue madame françoise
gatel à la parole pour le groupe union
des démocrates et indépendants union
centriste
madame la présidente merci monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues je voudrais
évoquer la situation catastrophique et
préoccupante du secteur du btp avec
l'inquiétude grave sur le maintien des
emplois à la situation économique
catastrophique de ce secteur aux effets
négatifs de la loi allure viennent se
rajouter des contraintes administratives
lourdes je voudrais évoquer le conte
pénibilité dont monsieur sapin dit
lui-même qu'il impraticable mais je
voudrais surtout évoqué la
réglementation extrêmement contraignante
sur le travail des mineurs
certes contrainte à vocation préventive
mais qui rendent tout simplement
impossible l'apprentissage d'un vrai
métier dans l'entreprise
ainsi en bretagne depuis cinq ans le
secteur du btp a perdu 800 postes
d'apprentis alors qu'on connaît la
longue tradition quantitatifs et
qualitatifs de formation de ce secteur
devraient aussi évoquer monsieur le
ministre la question des salariés
détachés d'entreprise localisés dans
l'union européenne
nous savons que bon nombre d'entre elles
ne respectent pas la réglementation en
vigueur soit sur les conditions de
travail soient sur les salaires
le nombre d'emplois des tâches est passé
de 26 mille je crois en 2008 après 2
enfin plus de 200 milles en 2013 donc
même un peu plus
trois cent mille dit au canton compte
les emplois des tâches et non déclaré et
que cette situation a engendré en
ille-et-vilaine enfin contribué entre
autres à une perte d'emploi dans le btp
de 2000 emplois alors certes la loi
savary 2014 a mis en place un dispositif
assez coercitif
pour lutter contre la fraude mais
monsieur le ministre les fraudeurs ne
connaissent pas les 35 heures et nous
savons que ces entreprises amène
beaucoup de salariés à travailler le
soir le week-end et les jours fériés et
qu'il est indispensable de mieux cibler
ses contrôles
donc monsieur mini je voudrais vous
demander quelles sont les propositions
concrètes que vous avez à nous apporter
sur un meilleur ciblage de la lutte
contre la fraude destructrice d'emplois
et surtout comment le gouvernement
compte consignes sur sa volonté très
louable en matière de développement de
l'apprentissage et la réglementation
très stricte qui constitue un frein à
l'embauché
merci à tous chers collègues monsieur le
ministre pardon merci madame la
présidente
pour être tout à fait clair dans ma
réponse je ne reprendrai pas les
attendus de votre question je les
partage
c'est vrai qu'il ya une dégradation
assez sensible de l'emploi dans le
secteur du bâtiment et des travaux
publics
c'est vrai qu'il ya une augmentation
très sensible de du nombre de
travailleurs détachés ce qui en soi
n'est pas un problème quand ils sont
déclarés on peut considérer qu'il ya
aujourd'hui plus de 350 mille
travailleurs détachés dans notre pays et
plus de 100 milles dans le secteur du
bâtiment et des travaux publics
vous me demandez quelles sont les
dispositions que nous comptons prendre
pour lutter contre le travail des tâches
est il légal c'est-à-dire non déclarés
alors je vais vous dire nous allons vous
savez ici vous avez adopté nous avons
adopté les parlementaires ont adopté la
loi dite savary qui lutte contre le
travail des tâches et illégale contre le
travail illégal et donc nous allons
augmenter bien évidemment fortement la
menthe administrative qui va être
augmenté dans des proportions très élevé
pour qu'elle soit un effet dissuasif
nous allons avoir la possibilité ça va
sortir et sans être précisés de
suspendre la prestation de service
international en cas de manquement grave
aux règles de détachement nous allons à
la demande de la fédération du bâtiment
d'ailleurs mettre en place une carte
d'identité professionnelle s'était
demandée depuis près de dix ans par la
fédération du bâtiment
je suis content de pouvoir y répondre je
vous le dis
parce qu'il y avait des freins un peu
partout à cette mise en garde de mise en
place de cette carte professionnelle
nous allons également dans le domaine de
l'apprentissage c'est une réponse
concrète que je vais faire suite à la
réunion qui avait tenu président de la
république le 19 septembre pour lever
les freins à l'apprentissage
je vais prendre un décret concernant le
le travail dit les travaux dits
dangereux des jeunes qui va sortir
prochainement avant le mois de mai où on
va faciliter l'accès sur met en danger
pour autant les jeunes les jeunes par un
aspect déclaratif et non plus de
demandes d'autorisation des entreprises
ça va correspondre à ce que vous
attendiez les objectifs de contrôle vont
être réévalués à la hausse et je
prendrai dans l'est la semaine qui vient
les semaines qui viennent
une initiative très fortes pour lutter
contre le travail illégal avec le
premier ministre
merci monsieur le ministre madame gatel
voulait répondre oui rapidement merci
monsieur le ministre on compte sur vous
pour favoriser le développement de
l'apprentissage mais aussi je le répète
pour les contrôler le week-end et jean
ferry il m'est arrivé dans ma commune de
me promener de voir des peintres sur un
chantier je me suis approché s'envoler
comme une volée de moineaux et c'était
un dimanche après midi
monsieur le ministre merci merci la
parole est à madame catherine procaccia
pour le groupe union pour un mouvement
populaire
merci madame la présidente bonjour
monsieur le ministre bonjour mes
collègues mes chers collègues
une étude récente de la dares vient
bouleverser bon nombre d idées reçues
sur les cdi
elle montre chiffres à l'appui qu'un peu
plus d'un tiers des contrats à durée
déterminée terminé sont rompus avant la
fin de la première année un chiffre
étonnant eu égard la situation d'emploi
et un chiffre d'autant plus paradoxale
que le taux de ces rupture anticipée est
en croissance
autre bouleversement des idées
préconçues
la première cause de rupture anticipée
n'est pas la fin de la période d'essai
mais la démission du salarié dans plus
de 16 % des cas l'étude souligne la très
faible part des licenciements 3% et
celle complètement marginal des ruptures
conventionnelles
enfin il apparaît qu'il ya par des cdi
rompu avant le premier anniversaire est
particulièrement élevé chez les 15 24
ans plus de 45 8 6% et qu'une des
missions sur deux concerne les personnes
les moins qualifiées
ces chiffres monsieur le ministre doit
vous interpellez autant que moi
les jeunes sont-ils instables sont ils
mal préparés aux réalités du travail
salarié
il montre en tout cas l'inefficacité des
politiques pôle public qui incite les
entreprises à proposer des cdi aux
jeunes sans qualification le cdi n'est
donc plus synonyme de stabilité ni de
fidélité pour l'entreprise puisque 50%
des contrats sont rompues la deuxième
année et 60 % la troisième année
monsieur le ministre puisque le cdi
n'attire plus les nouvelles générations
du 21e siècle
envisagez-vous comme l'a fait un moment
le premier ministre de rapprocher les
obligations contraintes des différents
contrats afin de faciliter la vie en
particulier des petites entreprises et à
défaut de créer un contrat unique comme
le suggèrent les économistes et notre
prix nobel français jean tirole
allez-vous proposer l'alignement des
dispositions des contrats courts cdd et
cdi de courte durée
merci cher collègue monsieur le ministre
vous avez la parole merci à madame la
présidente
mesdames un monsieur le sénateur madame
la sénatrice pro cassia vous vous avez
raison dans l'analyse effectivement les
ruptures conventionnelles
depuis leur mise en place dans les
années 2008 2009 ont connu un franc
succès et celui ci ne se dément pas il
ya une augmentation des ruptures
conventionnelles en 2014 2 6% pour
atteindre le nombre record de 333 1000
rue ptu reconventionnelle mais faut dire
que entre 2012 et 2013 donc il n'y a pas
de lien avec la politique menée j'avais
7 2% donc
la moyenne mensuelle elle tourne depuis
2009 entre 25000 excusez moi
l'expression les mauvaises années trente
mille les bonnes années pour les
ruptures cent en mai les partenaires
sociaux sont très attachés vous le savez
à ces ruptures conventionnelles
permettent une souplesse que le musée du
travail peut regretter de temps en temps
mais qui existe et qui est là c'est vrai
que c'est ça signifie la fin des cdi
pour à peu près 20% des cas sur des
raisons qui sont celles que vous avez
évoquées et donc elles sont pas
uniquement liées à la conjoncture ces
ruptures mais bien souvent à des
démissions ou des licenciements
très peu aux licenciements et beaucoup
d'autres démissions négocier je ne sait
en tirer des conclusions sans
immédiatement m'attirer les foudres des
partenaires sociaux donc je m'arrêterai
là et je vous laisserai les commentaires
ce que je peux dire c'est que cette
évolution est elle le signe que le cdi
est dépassé il reste quand même même si
la part des cdd dans les embauches vous
le savez continue d'augmenter malgré les
dispositions qui avaient été prises
alourdissant la fiscalité pour les
entreprises qui faisaient trop trop
recours la proportion des salariés en
cdi un peu varié depuis 15 ans et reste
largement majoritaire ses 87 % des
salariés
est-ce qu'il faut passer à un autre type
de contrat contrat unique je pense que
nous avons en france tous les types de
contrats nécessaires pour répondre à la
souplesse nécessaire des entreprises à
la garantie pour pour le salarié et donc
cela mériterait j'en suis désolé une
plus grand une plus longue analyse je
suis prêt à reprendre cette discussion
merci beaucoup chers collègues madame
rocade chose que vous voulez oui
monsieur le ministre vous m'avez répondu
d'une façon très globale sur les
ruptures conventionnelles sur les types
de contrats laisser dit mais moi je vous
interrogeait uniquement sur l'étude de
la dares sur les démissions des jeunes
qui ont entre 17 et 25 ans et qui
démissionnent la concurrence de 40 % dès
la première année donc c'était un cas
très spécifique
d'autant plus que dans ma question je
disais bien qu'il n'y avait qu'un taux
marginal que je
vais vous citer qui est de 1 7% de
démission par rupture conventionnelle
donc vous m'avez répondu généralement
sur l'emploi moi je vous interrogeait
sur l'emploi et sur l'emploi des jeunes
quand je vous parlais du contrat unique
je parlais aussi mais du contrat unique
uniquement pour les périodes courtes
si vous avez 40 % des gens qui
démissionne
la première année où la fin des contrats
la première année d'un cdi c'est qu'il
ya un problème par rapport au cdi et je
me demande si ce problème n'est pas lié
justement à toutes les charges qui
pèsent sur les cdd et les contributions
qui ont été augmenté récemment dans la
rade sécurisation de l'emploi
merci la parole est à jean désessard
pour le groupe écologiste allons pardon
excusez moi à monsieur pierre yves
collombat excusez moi monsieur collombat
alors là vraiment il ya un truc hein oui
je suis plus maigres c'est pour ça
monsieur le ministre
durant le quinquennat de nicolas sarkozy
le nombre de chômeurs de catégorie à a
augmenté de 700 14000 à mi-quinquennat
de françois hollande l'augmentation est
déjà de 610000 je vous fais grâce de
l'évolution des chiffres du chômage de
longue durée des jeunes des seniors des
sources et du sous-emploi chronique ces
chiffres vous les connaissez mieux que
moi ce ne sont pourtant pas les mesures
fiscales favorables entreprises qui ont
manqué cissé en est un bon exemple
ni les mesures de flexibilisation du
marché du travail ou pour libérer la
croissance et l'activité pour reprendre
le titre d'un projet de loi qui fait
l'actualité
après comme avant le changement le
diagnostic et les remèdes sont toujours
les mêmes les résultats aussi
apparemment
et pourtant la conjoncture semble
n'avoir jamais été aussi favorables
comme le rappelait michel sapin dans un
récent entretien il n'y a plus d'excusé
externe taux de l'euro ou du pétrole
politique monétaire restrictive de la
bce où alternent pour décharger des
impôts pour faire valoir à faire valoir
pour expliquer l'absence de croissance
en france disait le ministre qui
concluait il ya aujourd'hui
plein de bonnes raisons pour que
l'activité économique redémarre
sauf que absence de raison visiblement
n'est pas raison d'où cette supposition
si au lieu de s'acharner à libérer
d'entravé imaginaire une mystérieuse
croissante tout prête à bondir
on essayait de la cré cette croissance
par l'investissement public tout
spécialement par celui des collectivités
territoriales suspecte de trop dépenser
qu'en pense le maire de dijon monsieur
le ministre
merci monsieur que l'on bat monsieur le
ministre vous avez la parole
merci madame la présidente merci
messieurs merci monsieur le sénateur
pierre-yves collombat pour votre
question et l'humour qui est mis à la
fin de cette question c'est vrai le le
nombre d'inscrits à pôle emploi je
reprécise les choses a augmenté de 2008
à 2012 de sept cent quarante mille c'est
pas la peine de rajouter monsieur le
sénateur il a augmenté de 550000 depuis
le début de ce quinquennat c'est déjà
suffisant pour que vous n'en rajoutez
pas donc moi je ne le nie pas et en la
matière les raisons elles sont elles
sont assez évidentes dans notre dans
notre pays nous nous avons fait je crois
collectivement je le dis ici
collectivement le choix du chômage de
masse collectivement parce que nous
avons toujours privilégié la
sécurisation la plus générale par
rapport à la mise en compétition je vais
vous donner quelques exemples pour
expliquer mon propos dans les autres
pays quand on fait la comparaison il y à
un développement formidable du du temps
partiel mais dans les autres pays le
temps partiel n'entre pas dans les
chiffres de comptabilisation de l'emploi
en grande bretagne c'est parce que je
suggère soyons clairs je vous donne des
quelques explications en grande bretagne
a le contre à 0,1
c'est parce que nous voulons mais ça
permet de ne pas comptés comme chômeurs
les personnes qui ont un contrat 0 h 15
minutes par exemple dans en mini
en allemagne c'est 7 million et demi de
mini jobs mais ils sont pas
comptabilisés comme comme demandeur
d'emploi
nous nous avons une catégorie assez
spécifique en france qu'est la catégorie
de ceux qui travaillent plus 78 heures
nous les considérons comme les chômeurs
titre de la catégorie c est donc je
voudrais vous dire que comparaison comme
vous l'avez dit monsieur le sénateur
n'est pas raison merci monsieur le
ministre pierre yves collombat pour la
réplique monsieur le ministre je vous
remercie pour votre réponse stricte
observance libéral vous nous dites le
choix le choix serait entre le chômage
de masse et vous ne l'avez pas dit mais
c'est moi qui le dit le choix de la
précarité
moi mon problème c'est pas celui là
mon problème c'est le choix entre la
politique de l'offre poursuivi jeudi
depuis l'ancien le dernier ce précédent
quinquennat mais je pourrais dire depuis
depuis 20 ans le choix donc entre la
politique dite de l'offre et la
politique de la demande
keynes déjà noté qu'il avait fallu un
certain temps pour qu'à son époque on
réalise qu'ils avaient vraiment une
crise sérieuse à l'horizon j'espère que
ça durera moins longtemps mais je crains
que non si monsieur collombat alors là
parfois les donc à monsieur jean
désessard pour le groupe écologiste
merci madame la présidente selon l'insee
le 31 décembre 1962 pays comptait 20
millions 583 milles personnes en
situation d'emploi 52 ans plus tard le
31 décembre 2012
ce sont 26 millions trois cent dix neuf
mille personnes qui travaillent soit une
augmentation de 27 9 % durant la même
période selon l'insee le nombre d'heures
travaillées dans la totalité des
branches est passé de 43 milliards
501 millions en 60 à 30 9 milliards 872
millions en 2012 soit une diminution de
8,3 pour cent ce qui signifie qu'un
travailleur de 2012 passe 20 de plus
pour ce 28 % moins de temps trail que
son père en 1960
comment l'expliquer un ralentissement de
l'activité non
car c'est durant ces cinquante deux ans
le pib par habitant a été multiplié par
trois ainsi un travailleur de 2012 créer
autant de richesses en une heure que 3,8
travailleurs en 1960 il y a besoin de
moins de main d'oeuvre ce qui entraîne
deux conséquences majeures pose du
chômage et précarisation des
travailleurs avec plus de 83 % des
embauches réalisées en cdd fin 2014
aussi je souhaite ici m'intéresser au
mouvement de fond qui traverse aux
sociétés depuis les trente glorieuses
l'augmentation de la productivité
mécanisation hier robotisée robotisation
aujourd'hui et intelligence artificielle
demain ce n'est pas fini les moyens
techniques optimiser au maximum le temps
de travail
d'où la nécessité du partage du travail
dans les années 60 et 70 sa diminution
du temps de travail salarié avait une
connotation positive
le réel problème c'est que le fruit de
ces gains de productivité a été accaparé
par le capital au lieu d'être consacrée
à l'emploi entre 1918 et 2012
les dividendes versés aux actionnaires
des sociétés non financières ont
quasiment triplé passant de 3 % à 9 % de
la valeur ajoutée totale durant la même
période la part de cette valeur ajoutée
à l'eau et à la masse salariale a chuté
de 8% dès lors monsieur le ministre
quelles mesures comptez vous prendre
pour que tout le monde ait accès à
l'emploi dans une société où l'emploi
dans sa globalité sera moindre
merci monsieur le ministre vous avez la
parole merci à madame la présidente
mesdames messieurs les sénateurs
oui c'est une question de fond que vous
posez le sénateur des essarts c'est dur
d'y répondre en deux minutes à vous en
conviendrez
la durée annuelle du travail elle a
baissé dans tous les pays développés
depuis 1950
c'est un mouvement de fond qui a été
lancée on pourrait même dire depuis le
début du 20e siècle
quand on regarde le travail et même la
nuit on faisait même travailler les
enfants la nuit c'est plus le cas
aujourd'hui même si je vais prendre les
dispositions pour leur permettre d'avoir
accès à l'apprentissage pour un certain
nombre
de travaux et donc comment ça s'est
développé de deux manières d'abord par
un effort de productivité vous en doutez
partout dans tous les pays développés
et puis par une baisse en france mais
pagaille pas qu'en france la durée
collective du travail dans tous les pays
de l'europe il ya une baisse de la durée
collective du travail
et puis il ya eu le développement du
temps partiel alors il ya le temps
partiel choisi et puis il ya le temps
partiel subi vous le savez donc nous
avons essayé de lutter contre le temps
partiel subi pour permettre à temps
partiel choisi là encore les solutions
sont très différentes suivant les pays
je citais tout à l'heure le cas de
l'allemagne où le taux excusez moi c'est
pas très joli d'employabilité des femmes
est beaucoup moins élevé qu'en france
parce que faute faute de crèches faute
d' aide à domicile dans les pour le
moment pour élever les enfants
et bien après les femmes reprennent
souvent en allemagne des du travail à
temps partiel temps partiel choisi ou
subi je ne sais pas je porterai pas
jugement et donc est ce que c'est là
était né luc table c'est la question de
fond que vous poser est ce que cette
baisse tendancielle du du temps du
travail est inéluctable je pense que si
malgré l'alignement des planètes que
nous connaissons en ce moment je parle
de situation économique qui devrait
s'améliorer en 2015 la croissance ne
partait jamais dans le pays la question
vous posez elle devrait être posée à
tout le monde
merci monsieur le ministre monsieur
desessard pour la réplique rapidement
monsieur le ministre a compris ma
question sont il l'a dit lui-même avec
deux minutes il pouvait pas y répondre
il a compris ma question c'est de dire
est ce que en fin de compte on court pas
avec une croix derrière une croissance
qui ne reviendra pas et plutôt que de
distribuer l'argent capital et de
vouloir faire travailler tout le monde
plus est ce qu'on pourrait pas la
distribuer à la masse salariale ce qui
permettrait d'embaucher plus de monde
c'est ça la question qui est posée donc
en juillet deux mondes est sage et dire
quelles mesures on fait pour qu'on
rétablisse un équilibre que les salariés
aient davantage de masse salariale et
que cette masse salariale sera
distribuée de façon plus équitable entre
les salariés
voilà la proposition dont nous pourrons
discuter lorsque nous
on davantage que deux minutes pour le
débat merci la parole est à monsieur
alain richard pour le groupe socialiste
la présidente moi j'aurais parlé d'un
sujet qu'on peut effectivement j'espère
évoqué en deux minutes qui est un peu
d'approfondissement sur justement
l'évolution de ces chiffres
parce que je suis frappé de voir en
regardant les corps des dernières années
qu'il ya eu des années où le nombre de
chômeurs suivant la définition du bureau
international du travail qui est celle
qui sert dans toute l'europe pour faire
des comparaisons d'un pays à l'autre
était très proche du nombre de
demandeurs d'emploi français dénombrés
par le comment par pôle emploi alors que
au cours des dernières années c'est
l'écart commence en 2010 l'écart s'est
de nouveau beaucoup créé creuser et
aujourd'hui on a deux millions huit cent
mille et quelques demandeurs d'emploi
recensés par l'obésité et 3 millions 4
recensés par par nos services publics et
donc quand je vois enfin j'ai essayé de
regarder quelle était la définition du
demandeur d'emploi ya quelques petites
différences mais me paraissent quand
même avoir du mal à expliquer à un écart
aussi important et en particulier je me
pose la question puisque évidemment dans
un cas comme dans l'autre on ne tient
pas compte des demandeurs d'emploi
indemnisés c'est l'ensemble des gens
disponibles pour l'emploi et n'ayant
aucune activité
mais est ce que dans le décompte que
fait nos plus faible que fait le bts que
l'absence de
là des mises à sion n'aboutit pas à ne
pas compter un certain nombre de
demandeurs d'emploi en tout cas comme
nous sommes amenés à tout moment et
notamment justement pour apprécier ce
que donne ne donne pas les politiques
économiques on fait forcément des
comparaisons avec nos partenaires
européens qui utilisent tous la même
statistique
je crois que ce serait utile que nous
comprenions mieux s'il ya un biais d'un
côté ou de l'autre
et si le cas échéant sa conduirait à
ouvrir une concertation pour faire
évoluer notre propre dénombrement merci
sarko laine monsieur le ministre vous
avez la parole oui merci madame la
présidente madame le sénateur sur le
sénateur alain richard ces questions de
fond que vous posez qui suscite
d'ailleurs beaucoup de quiproquos et
d'incompréhension effectivement au
niveau international le nombre de
demandeurs d'emploi reconnu par le bit
et qui sert de comparaison
internationale s'élève fin 2014
excusez moi à quelques centaines près à
deux millions huit cent quatre-vingt
mille et le nombre de demandeurs
d'emploi inscrits en catégorie a à pôle
emploi j'ai bien en catégorie à s'élève
à trois millions quatre cent
quatre-vingt mille donc nous avons un
écart de plus de 600 milles entre les
deux statistiques
moi ça m'a intéressé comme s'intéresse
tout toute personne qui aime les
comparaisons chiffrées et véridique et
véritable parce que en 2009-2010
mesdames messieurs les sénateurs il n'y
avait pas d'écart entre les deux ans
2009-2010 en 2010 très exactement il y
avait deux millions cinq cent mille
personnes reconnues comme demandeurs
d'emploi par le bureau international du
travail au sens du bureau international
du travail
les deux millions cinq cent mille les
demandeurs d'emploi au titre des
catégories 1 2 de pôle emploi alors que
s'est il passé
c'est pas ces deux phénomènes qui
explique cette différence de 600000 je
dis bien de 600000 il en existe d'autres
p2 que j'ai pointé du doigt c'est
d'abord la dispense de recherche
d'emploi qui a été mise en place pour
les seniors cette dispense de recherche
d'emploi a fait que ce qui était pas
comptabilisé parce qu'ils étaient
justement dispensés de recherche
d'emploi se sont retrouvés inscrits à
pôle emploi s'est on peut compter ça
viendrait en moins si vous le dax est
petit et l'analyse à 180 milles de 2008
à 2012 qui se sont retrouvés inscrits à
pôle emploi alors qu' il ne l'était pas
avant il était dans la même situation
est encore 200 milles depuis 2012
donc nous avons là près de 400 mille
demandeurs d'emploi qui sont des
demandeurs d'emploi qui n'était pas
demandeur d'emploi et qui n'ont pas
changé de situation ce qui explique déjà
la différence
on peut penser également que le fait de
permettre l'inscription à pôle emploi au
bout de quatre mois de de travail au
lieu de six mois et a eu aussi un effet
sur l'inscription il faut conclut emploi
voilà c'est un vrai sujet mais
j'aimerais bien venu de pouvoir y
revenir à un moment merci madame la
présidente monsieur à l'agresseur pas de
commentaire dans un échange aussi bref
mais je crois vraiment qu'il faut que
nous nous posions la question justement
de l'avenir et de la haie et de la
pertinence de cette catégorie
particulière dispense de recherche
d'emploi parce que il s'agit de
personnes qui sont potentiellement
employables dont certains ont le souhait
de retrouver une activité
alors que pour des raisons sociales pour
des raisons de d'éviter la surcharge des
services m'ont dit vous n'êtes pas
obligatoirement notamment regarde le
droit à indemnité tenues de rechercher
un emploi
c'est une chose mais ce sont bien les
demandeurs d'emploi donc moi j'ai du mal
à imaginer une solution qui consisterait
à parce que là ce serait mon avis
vraiment une
comment dire une manipulation de
statistiques j'ai du mal à imaginer que
des personnes qui ne sont pas l'âge de
la retraite qui n'ont pas acquis leurs
droits complets qui sont employables ne
puisse plus être comptée comme comme
demandeur d'emploi donc je crois qu'il
faut approfondir cette question là mais
ça ne m'explique pas tout à fait
pourquoi du coup ces gens là sont
comptés
si dire que l'obésité ne compte que les
gens qui effectivement sont en recherche
active
c'est ça mais mais je crois honnêtement
que il faut plutôt se poser la question
de savoir si cette notion de dispense
définitive de recherche d'emploi n'est
pas quelque chose à revoir merci
beaucoup monsieur richard jean baptiste
lemoyne à la parole pour le groupe union
pour un mouvement populaire
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre nous connaissons
malheureusement tous dans nos
départements des entreprises en
difficulté des femmes et des hommes de
l'ouvrier au chef d'entreprise qui
désespèrent de pouvoir sauvegarder leurs
activités alors les chiffres sont là ils
sont durs très durs 3.5 millions de
chômeurs en décembre l'apprentissage qui
a continué à chuter et ils sont plus
alarmant encore pour la bourgogne que
nous avons en commun
au troisième trimestre on pourra salarié
marchand se dégrade avec un recul deux
fois plus important qu'en france
métropolitaine alors peut-être me direz
vous monsieur le ministre que la hausse
ralentit mais l'horizon de la baisse
s'éloignent chaque mois plus peut-être
avez-vous dit monsieur le ministre à
l'instant qu'un certain alignement des
planètes est en cours avec fictivement
la baisse du prix du pétrole et de
l'euro
néanmoins nous ne pouvons pas
éternellement attendre le salut des
conditions extérieures
alors que faire pour reprendre une
célèbre interrogations vous avez recours
aux emplois aidés effectivement comme
tous les gouvernements avant vous
d'ailleurs c'est juste mais c'est une
réponse partielle
nous savons que 60% des personnes ayant
occupé un emploi aidé non marchand
malheureusement sont en situation
d'inactivité six mois après la fin de
leur contrat
vous avez mis en place le cic eu certes
mais son impact est ralentie par le
décalage d'un an qui est inhérent à son
caractère de crédit d'impôt et de plus
il ne s'applique pas directement sur la
feuille de paye donc le lien avec le
coût du travail n'est pas totalement
réalisé pour certains alors nous devrons
face à cela je pense continuer à alléger
un certain nombre de contraintes de
toutes natures qui pèsent sur le travail
aux deux points des cotisations
retraites complémentaires santé un pack
du dispositif de pénibilité c'est vrai
que de nombreux retours sur le terrain
nous font dire qu'il ya là beaucoup de
contraintes supplémentaires alors nous
avons chantier de la simplification de
l'environnement de l'entreprise la
négociation sur les irp et vous reprenez
la main monsieur le ministre vous nous
assurer qu'il n'y aura pas de
contraintes supplémentaires pour
très petites entreprises il y a
également tout le chantier effectivement
de la remise en route de l'apprentissage
de la voie professionnelle
monsieur le ministre quel est votre plan
d'action pour les six prochains mois les
réunions de programmation travail
gouvernemental ont eu lieu quel est le
plan de match
de votre point de vue merci monsieur le
ministre vous avez la parole merci
madame la présidente mesdames messieurs
les sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur jean baptiste
lemoyne nous partageons ensemble
le fait d'être élu d'une belle et région
et heureusement dons par rapport à la
moyenne nationale le taux de chômage est
moins élevé que la moyenne nationale
permet de le dire parce que vous savez
de région à région finalement savary et
à ses apports de les variations sont
assez importantes 8,5 en bretagne et 13%
dans les endroits industriels les plus
frappés mais c'est pas ça le sens de
votre question nous avons fait un
certain nombre de réformes structurelles
je les cite je sens les développer vous
comprendrez pourquoi nous avons mis en
place un certain nombre de réponses pour
aider les publics les plus fragiles à
retrouver un emploi
on peut en penser ce qu'on veut mais il
n'empêche que les emplois d'avenir c'est
aujourd'hui un succès nous avons
amélioré avec les partenaires sociaux
les incitations à la reprise d'emploi
par exemple pour redonner comment dire
de la très au fait de reprendre un
emploi les droits rechargeables en la
matière sont un dispositif est un
dispositif intéressant nous avons
réformé la formation professionnelle de
manière substantielle à travers la mise
en place du compte personnel de
formation qui va permettre à des
chômeurs de pouvoir se former ce qui
n'était pas le cas précédemment et c'est
pour ça que je disais que le choix avait
été fait je le dis avant du chômage de
longue durée par tout le monde
j'ajouterai que nous avons mis en oeuvre
jeu malgré des difficultés au départ le
relance de l'apprentissage et donner
l'exemple mais décrets qui vont sortir
et de de narguer d'inscription en
septembre en octobre et nous verrons les
effets positifs l'année prochaine nous
avons aussi les partenaires sociaux qui
ont mis en place la loi de sécurisation
de l'emploi
enfin nous avons entamé la réforme du
conseil des prud hommes pour sécuriser
l'engagement que vous me demandez de
prendre je le prends 2
vous il n'est pas question d'alourdir
les contraintes qui pèsent sur les pme
tpe
c'est le sens de votre question au
contraire ce qu'il faut c'est tout en
garantissant bien sûr les droits des
salariés n'est pas question d'y toucher
c'est donner à ces petites et moyennes
entreprises
là où il ya un gisement d'emplois plus
de souplesse plus de facilité plus
d'agilité pour pouvoir enregistrer des
personnes monsieur lemoine voulu dire un
mot merci mr le président du président
la république ce matin évoqué dans sa
conférence de presse
la revalorisation de la voie
professionnelle des lycées
professionnels de l'éducation
prioritaire
il faut placer des mots aux actes et
c'est vrai que je me permets droit de
regretter justement que le gouvernement
auquel vous appartenez malheureusement
est retirée par exemple brienon sur
armançon de la zone des zones
d'éducation prioritaire que la région
bourgogne est fermé un lycée
professionnel à migennes donc vous voyez
que effectivement nous pouvons parfois
nous rejoindre sur un certain nombre de
deux pétitions de principe mais encore
faut-il que derrière les actes suivent
et ça c'est vraiment cruciale parce que
je suis persuadé que c'est au niveau
micro et non pas au niveau macro qu'on
va s'en tirer
c'est parce qu'un artisan va créer un
emploi de plus qu'une pme va quitter un
emploi de plus que petit à petit on va
réussir à gagner ce combat voilà merci
madame la présidente
merci chers collègues je vais suspendre
la séance elle sera reprise à 16 heures
pour la deuxième lecture de la
proposition de loi autorisant l'accord
local de répartition voilà pour cette
séance de questions cribles thématiques
vous avez vu pendant 45 minutes
le ministre du travail et de l'emploi
françois rebsamen répondre aux sénateurs
alors les questions ont fusé dès la
première question le communiste
dominique watrin a attaqué le ministre
sur le bilan du gouvernement
avec les nouveaux chiffres record du
chômage trois millions quatre cent
quatre-vingt seize mille chômeurs sans
aucune activité c'est le bilan pour
l'année 2014 un bilan qui est tombée la
semaine dernière le ministre a appelé
les sénateurs à ne pas en rajouter il
était parfaitement conscient dit il de
ce bilan assez désastreux et il a appelé
les sénateurs et bien à attendre que les
politiques du gouvernement notamment en
matière de flexibilité pour les
entreprises fassent leur effet une
réponse vous vous en doutez qui n'a pas
du tout satisfait les sénateurs
notamment dans la majorité
là ce qu'il fallait retenir de ces
questions cribles quant à moi je vous
retrouve à 18h pour l'audition de rémy
pfimlin président de france télévisions
par la commission de la culture ici au
sénat très bonne chute des programmes
sur les chaînes parlementaires